after 20 years u.s troops will be out of
afghanistan by the end of next month
president biden yesterday laid out the
final strategy for withdrawing the
remaining american forces and the
president defended the timeline
even as the taliban gains more strength
in the country
we did not go to afghanistan to
nation-build
and it's the right and the
responsibility of afghan people alone
to decide their future and how they want
to run their country
our charlie dagda is in kabul where he
spoke with the top u.s diplomat in
afghanistan about the possible dangers
to the u.s embassy after withdrawal
across the country districts are falling
to the taliban like
dominoes as u.s forces head for the exit
and militants inch ever closer to the
capital
the u.s embassy has been taking a hard
look at its own
security situation the top u.s diplomat
in afghanistan is ross wilson
uh we have added some additional quick
reaction capabilities
uh in the event that something happens i
mean where's case scenario
evacuation plans in place at this point
i don't think it's imminent
planning for evacuations in any post
like this
is serious business it's only a few
short miles from the u.s
embassy to the airport but on the
streets of kabul
if it came to an emergency evacuation
extracting
thousands of staff the roads are a no go
the only way is up even now
american diplomats shuttle back and
forth by helicopter
but what if the compound gets stormed
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a embassy in the of the united states
from afghanistan the saigon moment the
president was referring to
the emergency airlift of americans from
the then capital of vietnam
in 1975. more recently
the storming of the u.s consulate in
benghazi libya
that left four americans dead including
u.s ambassador chris stevens
no one here believes that moment is
imminent but
even tightening the noose around the
capitol is a concern
we're concerned about talib moves to
gain control over some of the highways
that are
important points of supply for for our
embassy
the taliban say they have no intention
of taking kabul by force or
storming the u.s embassy but they
consider all foreign forces
left behind as invaders and therefore
legitimate targets
vlad charlie dagetta kabul thank you
very much